buongiorno studenti oggi dottore fare
esperimento su invisibilità oggi totoro
invisibile ma se inservienti tirare il
dottore borotalco mostrare su amber
presenza nella stanza bastare basta
grazie bastardi bastare bastare
dottore inalato tutto bene adesso totò
che fa vedere come si fa esperimento di
visibilità ma se mi date un secondo dato
un secondo il dottore io volere anche
respirare nella vita grazie
[Musica]
oggi il dottore fa all'esperimento capa
di vedere come invisibilità funziona nel
mondo esseri umani averne due vasche
aver svuotato pesci tranquilli pesci e
al sicuro mangiato sushi prima avere qui
tutta tanica di taniche avere qua
acquario di olio pieno avere qua a
quadri di parco pieno
oggi totò che farà vedere invisibilità
prendere provetta rigorosamente ruota e
inserire pro bettina all'interno di
acquario di a dove da casa vedere
provetta attraverso l'acqua perché non
essere invisibile questo normale sennò
inserire però provetta tutta quanta
dentro l'acqua in provetta già vedersi
un pochino di meno chiaro quindi se vuoi
inserire la posta non una cassa dentro
acquah di piscina non avete veramente
poco questa qua e sarà commentato dal
se noi proviamo a prendere altra
provetta e fare medesimo esperimento in
tanica di olio noi inserire roberts
all'interno
è proiettato diano in the reader si
basino inserire turca quanto all'interno
quindi riempiendola di liquido in questo
caso olio provetta insolitamente
compagnia questa essere magia
no questa essere se noi prendere
provetta inserire all'interno di liquido
luce attraversare due materie acqua aria
se noi riempire di liquido tutta
provetta luci attraversare non più aria
ma attraversare solo acqua ma nell'olio
scomparire sas ticamente serve per
rafforzare questa teoria dottore aveva
fregato tutti voi dall'inizio perché qua
dentro non esserci soltanto provetta che
totò gaber e mezzo ma esserci un sacco
di altre cose carine piene di odio ad
esempio tanica number one nel esserci
anche signore signori incredibile tanica
number two e pacchetto torre all'inizio
di tutta questa roba prima essere tutto
qua dentro
se io cercare molto fondo trovare anche
suocera però non voleva capire quindi
troviamo fuori sono cose che nascosto a
volte inferiore
questo esperimento vi sia piaciuto totò
vin grattato tutto camicie per l'amore
totò riina boy buona giornata
meter e mi piace a video perché essere
molto importante produttore per comprare
detersivi per lavare
tutto tutto per lavare tutto e ci
vediamo i prossimi giochi esperimenti
incredibile tra due settimane perché
sabato si sabato notte lo ricordo
iscrivetevi al canale e non ci vediamo
al prossimo video esperimento estivo
[Musica]